Hey guys! How's it goin'?  It's Justine. Welcome back to my kitchen.
Today, you don't have to watch me bake a cake.
Because, how many times have i baked cakes on my channel?
A LOT!
You know the process.
Today we are making a Pac-Man themed cake.
E3 is coming up so I wanted to do something really fun
and video game inspired and I thought:
"Uh, a Pac-Man cake? That sounds really really easy."
So to start, I've got these little tiny cupcakes
that I'm also gonna ice to go around
so it's kind of like the little balls that Pac Man eats during the game
We're also going to make some cherries.
I've got some icing that I'm gonna dye yellow.
So I guess to get started I'm just gonna cut out his little mouth.
[Happy Music]
I think that looks perfect, actually.
Now I need him to go the other way.
Oops, hehe, he's gonna eat over here, hehe
So now I've go to dye our icing yellow.
I prepped everything but the icing I forgot.
That's a lot of dye.
Let's ice up our little Pac Man.
Oh, maybe it should have been a little more yellow.
Mmm, it's vintage.
He's been aging, he's aged very well, leave him alone.
Oops, hehe, he's been left out in the sun a little too long, hmmm sorry buddy.
[Happy Music]
I think I'm happy with what we've got going on so far,
I'm gonna clean up around the edges,
I'm gonna put his eye on,
and then we're gonna just, keep going.
[Happy Music]
Where's the torch at?
You're using a torch?
Yes, 'cause I kinda want to melt it a little bit.
Oh, there we go, oh that's quite, that's, that's melting now.
Okay, welp, that's exactly what I wanted to do.
So he had a nice, greasy eye.
Look at that.
[Music]
Pac Man is lookin goood.
Now we're gonna ice up some of these little guys, for his little balls.
[Music]
Now I gotta make my cherry.
Oh yeah.
One last one and then we are good to goooo.
Look at him!
I think it turned out so good!
Jen, come look!
[Happy Music]
*Gasp* Oh God
Oh nooooo, hehe
[Happy Music]
Oh! It turned out nice!
Thank you!
Are these supposed to be yellow?
[Pac Man Noises]
It's been a looong time.
They, they might be white, they potentially could be white.
But can't he eat other things?
That's why I've got cherries.
Ooohhh!
The balls might be white in the game, now that I think about it.
[Pac Man Noises]
But aren't there different color balls?
There's like, the little ghosts that he eats,
[Pac Man Noises]
There's a lot of things.
It looks really good, I'm proud of you.
Hey now, hey now, do you want to taste it?
No
We've eaten so many cakes today.
No, normally I'd say yeah, but, it looks good.
I'm gonna save it, I'm actually gonna put it in the freezer and save it.
Well, thank you guys so much for watching, and thank you Jennifer uh,
Approving of my beautiful artwork.
Very nice.
Happy E3, and I'll see you guys there.
Bye!!
[Music]